hey everybody what's up it's John Luke
and Ben hi there and we are checking out
some call of duty zombies we're gonna be
givin you some beginners tips on voyage
of despair you know the the point of
this video is if you are new to zombies
or it's been a while or you just want
some early quick tips on how to get
started on voyage of despair we got you
covered yeah we got packet punches to
look at we got all sorts of cool stuff
to go in and just check out on this
really cool a crazy boat yeah we're
gonna get you down the basics so you can
then spend your time looking for all
them sweet secrets so we're gonna be
playing void your despair we're gonna be
playing on casual for the purposes of
this video so it's easy for us to show
you but it's just a fun little PSA
casual is actually a really nice way to
kind of easy win if you just want to get
familiar with the map before you hop
over to normal I highly recommend it I
double down on that recommendation it's
a good time playing a casual all right
let's get going oh no an iceberg who
would have saw this coming oh geez
alright so the first thing we got to do
is just get to the poop deck okay I was
expecting to be professional about this
I'm trying real hard so we can do that
we just have to get to the other side of
the ship which is pretty easy it's just
kind of a straight shot you can go
through two ways we can go through these
state rooms which is down here that I'm
looking at or we can go up I like going
up and that's kind of one we've been
doing yeah so it is just a pretty
straight shot but there is also some
stuff you can kind of find along the way
you can occasionally find a couple of
the pieces for the equipment you need
they are random where they're placed but
let's see if we can find one no we
usually find yep all right so here's one
right here next to the wheel kill a guy
that dapper zombie gentleman a die poor
fellow yeah so so we've seen him here I
think we've also seen that same piece on
this side over here as well so they seem
to have like a couple different spots
they'll spawn in look at this mystery
box yeah so uh it doesn't I don't know
if it pops up every time but pretty
consistently you will find a mystery box
here at the grand staircase which I
find priests phille so that's kind of
why I like coming this way yeah now
there's this lower area here which we
can't access until we get the sentinel
artifact is which is what we're trying
to get because that thing will open up
sort of like the rest of the ship for us
it's kind of a stand-in for turning on
the power if you've played older Maps
yeah all right Ben would you like to
open the door I would like to do that
I'm actually gonna hit this mystery box
oh I get what do I get what do I get
what I get ah sweet sniper rifle it's
okay it's all right
it's a trench gun right here it's okay
trench gun the trench gun is actually
really nice if you pack a punch it
because it turns into a grenade launcher
which everyone loves a little bit of
grenade launcher it was a good time you
got it like last night when we were
playing and it was kind of a sight to
behold one good thing to point out is
throughout the level you'll find
actually like a map of the ship you'll
find it all over the place and this is a
really good way to kind of quickly
familiarize yourself where you need to
go so this is sort of like a good way to
just kind of get used to wear them
everything is I'm the matter yeah all
right let's get this door unlocked keep
going and we continue advancing towards
the end of the ship yep we're on the
promenade port deck we're gonna go up
here and all right we just got to get
through one more door and then over
there we can see is the artifact so
there's the artifact we're gonna grab
that in a sec by the way if you're
looking for an assault rifle you can get
the KN 57 right here that's always a
good option I feel like that's maybe one
of the earlier assault rifles you
grabbed yeah it's it's very good I'm a
big fan of it all right defend a lot of
things apparently okay so now that we
have the artifact we can activate the
pack-a-punch and the first way to
activate it is actually right over here
there is this like pedal CIL's we get
and we just you just have to activate
them and there is four pedestals
throughout the ship we're gonna show
where all four of them are so first one
is on the back end of the ship yep first
one to the back on the ship the other
one is actually gonna be right below us
yeah yeah I got ahead of you
the third class down these stairs keep
going and we're gonna go through the
provisions open that door and we're in
the engine room which is where we're
gonna find the second one here and we're
gonna have to head into the water now
you can actually drain the water which
is quite useful you don't have to drain
the water to progress so here's the
packet bunch right there
we highly recommend draining it highly
recommend draining it for one you can
drowned
yeah spend too long there's a teleporter
right there and also it seems like from
the couple of times that I've done this
the valve for draining can actually pop
up in different places as well oh okay
interesting alright so right here yeah
this light right here drain the water
you do get an achievement for waiting
toll what does it round twenty without
draining any of the water which we did
by accident because we couldn't figure
out how to drain the water for a while
yes so we're just kind of like swimming
around to do everything and then we
actually discovered that you could drain
the water from the achievement but in
the long run the draining the water is
actually probably pretty useful so
that's how you do that all right so we
need to head back on up right yeah uh
let's see this teleporter bodek let's
take this one all right so we're gonna
take these teleporters I can kind of
take you all over the ship very useful
actually I'm gonna hit up that mystery
box oh dude I just got the Kraken holy
crap oh so you've got the actual
cracking gun without having to like yeah
by the way this is like a gun that you
have to do like a hidden quest to get I
just kind of got it it's like an actual
cannon and I'm very into it so and
that's a fun surprise in this because
tip video you can get in all sorts of
cool fun tips I just use the mystery box
just they get the Kraken just use the
mystery box to solve all the problems
I'll show you guys where the third
pack-a-punch pedestal is so you just
gotta keep heading down the grand
staircase now that this is open I'm
gonna grab this swordfish I found max oh
thanks max and then down here in this
kind of a creepy dark area is the
third pedestal we're gonna activate that
one and then for the final pedestal we
actually have to head back to the start
of the ship on the forecastle how's it
look
Oh looks good yeah it's got three cannon
has three cannons that's pretty cool
that's ridiculous I love it
okay so the final pack-a-punch pedestal
is down here
perhaps the mail rooms we're gonna go
through these you open up this door
we're gonna open up that door you can
also drain the water down here yes well
this is the other place that you need to
drain the water in there's a part over
there on that box Oh I'll leave that for
you to pick up ah perfect I'll grab that
alright I found the valve drained it
perfect by the way this is where you can
grab the Titan which is an excellent
weapon highly recommend it very good
machine guns
it's perfect for it and then right here
is the final pedestal the last pedestal
you'll activate will be the one that
turns into the pack-a-punch are you
gonna are you packing what I think
you're packing do you I don't have
enough we might have to come back we're
gonna come back we're gonna definitely
definitely gonna come back for that cuz
I need to see what that does cuz holy
crap
okay so yeah so after the pack punch
disappears occasionally it will go in
one of those four places and the nice
thing is that when you are at a pedestal
where the pack-a-punch isn't it actually
just tells you straight up where it is
so you can always track it down whenever
you need to pack punch yeah so it's
actually pretty easy to keep an eye on
the pack a punch and know where it is
alright then so at this point we pretty
much have the majority of the ship
unlocked mm-hmm and we have the pack a
punch we kind of got the basics going so
at this point you're set to just start
looking for four mysteries and solving
riddles yeah
there is the equipment which we've been
finding a couple of parts for kind of
showed where some of those are we don't
have a full list unfortunately but I can
show you where they are where the
workbench is do you need for them are
yes believe the first workbench that you
can build the the shield right Sheila is
out here yeah
back of the ship exactly so right here
is where we can get the parts for the
riot shield which is really cool uh yeah
that thing's great it has like a shield
in the back so it's a good way to
protect yourself
I highly recommend getting that for sure
we already have one of those parts you
only need three you can track your parts
with the touch pad to make sure where
you are and the other workbench is in
the engine room yeah so both these these
workbenches are at the end of the ship
yeah the back of the ship I'm trying so
hard to not say dick this what it's
called man got a stern of the ship the
back of the ship the the the booty of
the ship yeah so here is the other
workbench where you build the distiller
which you're gonna need I think four
parts four so you build the thing
initially and then I think you have to
add something later on yeah we've
managed to build the initial thing but
then it we still needed it wouldn't let
us do anything with it quite yet we're
not 100% sure what that's good for but
it's there for you what is there for you
okay so those are all the basic tips to
kind of get you started we know where
the pack-a-punch is we know how to get
the power on the equivalent of the power
anyway we know where all the work
benches are for when you eventually find
all those parts at this point you're
pretty much all set to just start
exploring and discover secrets like how
to get this cool cracking gun cuz you're
probably not gonna get it from the
mystery box like I did in fact you know
why don't we end this video by pact of
punching this cracking gun and seeing
what kind of damage it does hell yeah
I'm into it
do you let's see what this thing does do
it do it what'd I get what I get what I
get whoo
oh it's kind of like a purple glowing
eye thing going on that's great so
thanks for watching guys let us know
what you think of this if we did an okay
job obviously there are plenty of other
videos on the internet with more
specific stuff if you're looking at how
to get things like the crack and gun you
can probably go check those out on the
internet but let us know what you think
and any other tips that you find useful
for this map leave them in the comments
below and have a wonderful day tell me
your zombie secrets I need them
things so cool John I'm very very
jealous I can't believe I got this I
can't either
I feel like we have to play this out now
at least cuz you have it